اصبح الموريتانيون للاسف الشديد اجانب
يعني في ارضهم لا يستطيعون ان يريجو اداره
رواتب بلديهم ولا يستفيدون منها نشكر
الاساس التي تواجهم الامور تواجهه
موريتانيا اليوم هو النقطي النهائي بنت
مقاربتها سنه على اقتصادعي هذه المقاربه
كانت كارثه على البلاد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هناك فساد هناك سوء اداره وهناك غياب
للشفافيه في موريتانيا
ادت الى ان المتوقع بالنسبه للاقتصاد
الموريتاني وبالنسبه لتنميه البلد لم يكن
في الموعد بسبب هذه الاتفاقيات المشحده
لا تحترموا اي قانون وهي مطارده في كل
انحاء العالم نتيجه لممارستها السيئه في
الفساد والاضرار بالبيئه والانتهاك يعني
همم الانظمه الاجتماعيه وبين انظمه يعني
همم ما في هويه تتقاسم عن طريق يعني همم
موضع فيها وعن طريق همم خبرائها وعن طريق
اليتها هذه الثروه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عندما يقول صياد بسيط ان الشركات الكبرى
تعتدي على الثروه البحريه بدون وجه بدون
وجود اي رقبه اصدق من اصدق الصياد الذي
يقتات ويعيش على الصيد ويتعرض الى هذه
الممارسات ام وصدق التقارير الرسميه
باسم الدوله الموريتاني من طرف اشخاص همم
رغد اليهم بتمثيل الدول الموريتانيا ما
الذي تغير تغيرت الاراده السياسيه هذه
الاراده السياسيه هي التي تطمئن اليوم
الموريتانيا
فقط ونوفر فرص عمل لا يقل موريتانيا
في هذا النظام الحالي لم يكن جزءا اصيلا
ومهما في النظام السابقين هم نفس الاشخاص